ich habe bereits vor einiger zeit auf
eine mail reagiert die ich von einer
russischen dame erhalten habe ich
brauche einen mann und suche einen mann
wenn du mir schreibt wird es gut
daraufhin habe ich auch auf ihre mail
geantwortet china sana harsch warum
sollen nicht antworten wenn du sehen
selten antworten und semikolon lg winzer
ja die hat mir jetzt noch mal eine mail
geschickt email kam natürlich wieder von
der wundervollen russischen dame namens
schnees hahn albano war das ist wirklich
der beschüsse name gehört habe anstatt
dass sie irgendwie schreibt hey luca was
geht bei dir schönen guten tag gegen k
wie geht's dir mal in folge schreibt sie
einfach nur business
ja das ist die bezeichnung von meinem
profil nicht mein name aber gut
wir lesen die welt mal weiter und zwar
schreibt sie dann hallo mit sieben
ausrufezeichen
sie werden vielleicht von meinem brief
überrascht sein aber ich habe den wunsch
mit jemandem zu kommunizieren und 40.000
punkte er wuchs im 1
dann kommunizieren miteinander ich bin
sehr einsam da haben wir was gemeinsam
ich werde dir kurz etwas über dich
erzählen mein name ist es hana ich bin
41 jahre alt das zum thema sie wird mir
etwas über mich erzählen meine größe ist
168 cm gewicht 58 kilogramm obwohl das
alter zwischen menschen keine bedeutung
für mich hat
ich will auch noch sagen wie viele haare
unter den achseln
es ist wichtig welche art von personen
nicht sein alter
ich arbeite jetzt in der ukraine in der
stadt odessa obwohl ich bin russe und
meine eltern und tochter leben in
russland in der stadt nur wars koren
burke region dies ist eine sehr kleine
stadt finde ich auf jeden fall sehr
schön dass sie mir jetzt sagt dass sie
eine tochter hat wo sie wohnt et cetera
pp doch gerade wo sie wohnt da will sie
mir noch viel mehr darüber berichten und
das tut sie jetzt auch etwas eigenartig
fließt und haben nicht persönliche von
der gegend hier zu gehen oder fahr und
dann habe ich eigentlich wechselvolle
moment arbeitet affäre christa plate und
endlich endlich zwei wochen und werde
nach ostern die tiere nicht viel
geschrieben haben eine tochter hat eine
familie wie sie vergeben und ich habe
auch ein enkel nicht gerade von jenen
die an den start gegangen und war eines
tages werde ich die kapelle die
traumfahrt einige jahre später ein
großes match und ich will karriere
spricht einen ernsthaften allerdings
sage beziehung haben alles gute in
meinem leben habe ich bin einfach ich
habe keinen freund
also sie berichtet mir hier darüber wie
scheiße ihr leben ist die ehepartner ist
gestorben und sie hat schon eine tochter
die auch schon verheiratet ist aber
davor sagt sie dass die 41 jahre alt ist
ich meine wann heiratet man
normalerweise so mit 25 oder so das
heißt sie muss mit 16 ein kind bekommen
haben
nö
wir lesen mal weiter schreibe dir nicht
jeden tag es gibt viel arbeit weist du
aber ich werde so oft schreiben wie ich
kann ich habe keinen computer zu hause
ich lebe in einer mietwohnung also habe
ich kein facebook oder hochtöner
sie sagt sie wohnt und einer mietwohnung
und in einer mietwohnung kann man keinen
facebook haben und keine hochtöner ist
jetzt auch musikproduzenten jordan
internet partnervermittlung und ich habe
viele fragebögen von männern ich kenne
den namen der website auf der ich dein
profil gesehen habe nicht aber es hat
mir sehr gut gefallen und ich wollte dir
schreiben wenn du mit mir jettes und ich
vielleicht in der zukunft trifft dann
warte ich auf deine antwort ich schicke
dir meine fotos ich denke mein erstes
foto zeigt mein gesicht nicht gut
würde ich auch immer so machen wenn ich
immerhin über eine partnervermittlung
kennenlernen würde ich etwas sagen hey
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich kennengelernt
habe aber ich glaube wir passen gut
zusammen hier sind einige bilder von mir
aber auf dem ersten bild ist mein
gesicht überhaupt nicht gut genau so
sollte man immer sonst angehen aber dann
meine damen und herren habe ich wirklich
meinen den anderen der mail geschaut
oder wann tatsächlich zwei bilder drin
die mir die schnell sein analog würden
nun an war die liebe dame hat mir
tatsächlich in die mails zwei bilder von
sich selbst gepackt er mich würd sagen
ich zeige euch mal einfach und zwar ist
das hier die schnell sahara wo ihr
gesicht nicht gut getroffen ist und der
zweite bild das sie mir geschickt das
ist tatsächlich ein ganzkörperfoto
wahrscheinlich in ihrer lieblingsstadt
und deshalb wo sie gerade wohn oder in
der ukraine keine ahnung ist auf jeden
fall dieses bild 41 jahre alt die
schnell seiner hier steht auf einer
straße danke dir schnell sana also du
bist ja ein bisschen meine russische
freundin jetzt hier gerade geworden
und wer denkt ja auch dass wir uns
zwischen uns beiden gewisse chemie
besteht
ich habe leider schon eine freundin mit
der jude zusammen bin sehr sehr
glücklich aber sie hatten auf jeden fall
nochmal eine mail geschrieben ich habe
halt auf diese mail die ich euch gerade
gezeigt habe nicht geantwortet weil ich
gedacht hat hey ich hab das schon wieder
drüber gemacht jetzt antwortet die mir
okay da will ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
mal drauf eingehen dann hat sie mit
tatsächlich eine woche später noch mal
geschrieben und ganz kurz einfach nur
wissen dass das ist wieder schneller
hana guten tag ich habe ihnen vor ein
paar tagen geschrieben schenken sie noch
einmal einen brief ich hoffe du
schreibst mir ja darauf habe ich
tatsächlich wieder nicht geantwortet
doch dann kam vor einigen tagen nochmal
eine mail von der lieben schnell sana
und da wurde so langsam klar hey
vielleicht ist sie gar keine echte
person sondern einfach nur irgendeinen
space camp computer der wegen der
scheiße schreibt denn dieser mail die
ich euch jetzt zeigen werde ging sie
wirklich davon aus dass ich hier schon
geantwortet habe ich zeige euch einfach
mal den anfang im business da geht es
direkt wieder persönlich los hallo hier
ist wieder schnell hana vielen dank für
deinen brief sehr schönes zu lesen es
tut uns leid gegen solange antworten zu
müssen sehr schwierige arbeitstage ich
hatte keine
das tut mir leid und schäme mich aber
ich hoffe du verstehst
erste sahne
habe die nicht geantwortet zweitens
warum sagst du uns
ich dachte du bist eine einsame person
in odessa in der ukraine aber gut dann
geht's auf jeden fall weiter um sie
schreibt ich hoffe dass unsere beziehung
weiter geht
hey ich bin luca ich bin jetzt nach fünf
mails mit einer russischen dame zusammen
ich schicke dir ein foto wir feiern den
geburtstag meiner freundin und das
zweite foto des profi fotografen ich
hoffe du wirst lieben ich habe ein
telefon aber es funktioniert nur in der
ukraine er akzeptiert ist nicht anrufe
aus anderen ländern ich kann ihre eltern
in russland nicht einmal anrufen
warum die zuletzt meine eltern aus
russland anrufen aber hier in der
ukraine mögen sie nach der revolution
kein russisch alle meine freunde gingen
zurück zu russland so beende ich meine
arbeit schnell wieder in russland ich
möchte mehr in russland sein vielleicht
sogar früher wissen sie ich wollte es
wirklich
ich verstehe mittlerweile echt nur noch
bahnhof ihr mann und ihre familie haben
mir geholfen dann gibt es einen
autounfall mit dem auto und mein mann
ist gestorben es war vor zehn jahren als
unsere tochter 15 jahre alt war und ich
habe meine trauer mit tochter erholt
sehr schwierig und schwierig aber ich
habe es geschafft
diese juckt mich halt alles ehrlich
gesagt herzlich wenig vielleicht ist es
langweilig und für sie nicht interessant
aber ich wollte nur jemanden um es zu
sagen ich weiß dass du es präsentieren
kannst ich fühlte mich danach besser
wörter
chinese
hahahaha du kannst dich mehr öffnet ich
finde es sehr interessant ich finde es
leichte das zu schreiben und ich hatte
glück ich habe dich getroffen ich bin
sehr glücklich ich möchte dich
kennenlernen und vielleicht nicht
treffen aber zuerst müssen wir uns
kennenlernen ich möchte ihnen ein paar
fragen stellen japan am akh na na na na
na na na na na
stell uns deine fragen wie ist dein
voller name ich heiße schnitt hana
ivanova aber verwandte und freunde
nennen mit hana ich denke du bist der
gleich nebenan kann man nicht auch
ansprechen klammer zu
mein name ist luca laser luca auf
instagram kann's mir gerne folgende sana
instagram ich habe am ersten dezember
geburtstag und ich werde 42 jahre alt
sein wie er holst du dich gerne was ist
deine lieblingsfarbe mein blau ist wie
in der luft oder im wasser im meer
welche musik magst du das machst du
filme der film titanic hat mir gefallen
becker was schreibt die für einen stuss
zusammen dies ist eine wunderschöne
liebesgeschichte musik ich liebe
klassische musik rest was ich liebe die
entspannung am meer mehr weil direkt bei
mir bei der arbeit vier klammern zu ich
schaue auch gerne fern ich liebe sport
zu schauen vor allem weltmeisterschaften
scheißegal was das für ein sport ist
hauptsache es ist der weltmeisterschaft
ich bin auch gerne in einem zelt
schlafen am feuer sitzen im allgemeinen
bin ich eine sehr positive person und
ich hoffe dass es genauso geht versteht
mich nicht falsch ich schreibe nicht
jeden tag ich habe viel arbeit ich bin
sehr müde ich werde es tun so bald wie
möglich schreiben warten sie ich freue
mich auf ihren nächsten brief dankeschön
auf jeden fall für diesen brief schnell
sana ich möchte jetzt gar nicht negativ
darauf reagieren
meine liebe dame falls das ganze sehen
sollte ich wissen der in einer beziehung
mittlerweile nevada ich hab dich echt
ganz so lieb ich weiß auch dass du mir
tatsächlich bei dieser mail auch wieder
bilder von dir dazu geschickt hast
einmal dass hier bei dem geburtstag
ich glaube das bist du das kleid rot wie
blut dann hat sie mir auch noch dieses
bild geschickt das ist sie glaube ich
dass es das bild von dem profifotografen
und das letzte bild was sie mir
geschickt hat ist glaube ich eines wo
sie sich ein bisschen entspannter mehr
sag ich mal haben uns was ist das hier
wahrscheinlich da in ihrer stadt in der
ukraine oder russland oder odessa oder
keine ahnung wo du auch immer jetzt
gerade lebst auf jeden fall waren das
drei mails die medisana noch einmal
geschrieben hat ich würde sagen ich
antworte darauf jetzt einfach mal dass
hier
jetzt auch mal ein bild von mir und mal
schauen ob sich mir noch einmal
antworten wird
[Musik]